babos what's gonna do we summon num num
come for you but this is the actual
lyrics true story end of watch now end
of watch kind of feels like one of those
found-footage type movies but it's not
completely a found-footage type movie
and it has to do with a couple of patrol
cops in LA probably the toughest job
that ever existed in the history of life
or at least most frustrating their
partners the wrong patrol they're going
around and Jake Gyllenhaal's recording
it for one of his college credits and so
we're sitting in the biz with them but
like I said it's not completely a found
footage movie there are scenes where
they kicking a door and the cameras on
the other side of the door but it still
looks found footage is like moments like
that I'm like what was someone recording
on the other end of the door so it's not
completely I found footage type movie so
you got to know that going into it and
in the end it's probably a good thing
I'm sick and tired of these
found-footage gimmicks I just want a
good movie turns out end of watch is
actually a good movie first of all you
have Gyllenhaal and Pena and the two
have crazy insane chemistry in terms of
cop chemistry these two are pretty much
the top of the line they got the
Harrison Ford Sean Connery chemistry
going on in this movie so you're like oh
this is legit you feel like they're
really cops I mean I imagine cops in the
real world are gonna watch this movie
and be like Landon how we do it you know
what as we civilians watch the movie
it's pretty legit and there are a couple
of hothead cops they're good at their
job the department recognizes it it get
a lot of props oh they do something else
then get another big bust and Gyllenhaal
starts getting more arrogant till they
start pissing off the wrong people and
in this movie you got some Mexican
cartel operating these are the guys
where I was like these guys are kind of
cartoony sometimes they're really
intense the really insane and the
recording all of it first of all I do
bad guys record their isn't that
just like a dumb bad guy thing to do
these professional Mexican cartel types
that butcher and torture people they're
gonna record them blowing people away I
don't get it now that I don't get it I
just don't buy it I guess they're really
intense dude they're in each other's
faces in each other's you're like
dude calm down there are a couple of
scenes when a fleet of dudes with ak-47s
just unload on a couple people and no
one gets hit you're like nobody nobody
got hit that's like you're getting in a
GI Joe cartoon territory right there was
like like the bullets are flying or
laser guns or whatever no one gets hit
we're really
at home is the fact that you feel like
you're riding along with these two cops
they address that being a cop has a lot
of paperwork which it does but they
don't concentrate on the paperwork you
get all the fun of being a cop and some
of the frustration the that you
don't want to see you know the realism
of being a cop also none of the
realistic paperwork that's just a
win-win right there Anna Kendrick's in
this movie she's always cool she's
always hot never hurts to be both but
yeah I love her in this movie what can
you say about Anna Kendrick except yep
she did it again it does have that chick
from Magic Mike though and immediately
when I saw her my mood dropped I don't
know why I was just like I hate your
face she has this stoic look on her face
you know like Arnold Schwarzenegger like
she just has too much food in her mouth
like she's just not impressed
she makes the Twilight chick look like
she has Haley Joel Osment acting talent
from like 1999 she's not in it much so
you know you deal with it in the end I
had fun with end of watch I loved the
main characters in end of watch
Gyllenhaal and Pena had insane chemistry
I love them as a cop movie I thought it
was great cop movies usually you're like
yeah I've seen this before this is fresh
it was a lot of fun and it takes place
in LA so you know you're gonna see some
I'm gonna say I would buy end of
watch on blu-ray I thought it was a
great cop movie what I would expect from
the writer of training day alright so
what is your favorite cop movie of all
time whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you